let's bring in farz maxad now he's the
director of strategic Outreach and a
senior fellow at the Middle East
Institute he joins us from Washington DC
good to have you with us so Joe Biden
says he has decided how to respond to
this attack in Jordan as kimy was just
saying he doesn't want to escalate a
wider War so what options are available
to
him well there's certainly a number of
options Laura and there's a great deal
of pressure particularly from the right
side of the political Spectrum in
Washington
to take a fight to Iran Iran has been
acting against American interest in the
region with plausible deniability really
using these militias to uh try and
thwart and push out American forces out
of Syria and Iraq and particular I think
these will be disappointed President
Biden clearly does not want to eate at
this time with Iran they're much more
interested in the ongoing diplomatic
process that we saw unfold in Paris the
sort of cuty Egyptian L mediation to
release hostages Israeli hostages and
try to bring about at least a temporary
ceasefire in Gaza so I think what the
Biden Administration will probably land
on is some kind of teered sustained
campaign against these militias in Syria
and Iraq possibly even targeting Iranian
officials in these countries something
similar to what they've been doing
against the huis in Yemen but stop short
of targeting Iran itself and nothing on
Iranian soil because of course Iran
insists that it is not responsible for
any of these attacks by groups that it
supports what do you make of that uh
what do you think its involvement
is yeah well that's a statement that's
kind of hard to believe anybody who
knows this region Poli it closely knows
that Iran has been arming and training
and equipping these groups for a number
of years now with hisa it's a
relationship that dates back to 40 years
strategically also they share the common
objective
they've stated time and again the
Iranians and these militias that they're
working together to push the United
States out of the region so yes the
Iranians want to leave that buffer they
want to have that plausible deniability
that enables them to strike an American
interest but yet again not have to pay
the price to leave room for the
administration to back down from having
to retaliate directly and I think in
this case they'll probably get what
they're looking for they will get a
measured response that will not Target
Iran proper that's interesting that Iraq
and Jordan have been very keen to
distance themselves from any military
threat so Iraq has already said that
it's very unhappy with the number of
retaliatory strikes that the US has been
carrying out and the number of Civilian
casualties that those of course it's
looking at uh insisting on the
withdrawal of US troops from Iraq do you
think it's going to carry out that
threat yeah I mean I think that's part
of the Dilemma that Iran is looking to
put the Biden Administration in this
happens this attack happens at a time
when the Iraqi government and the
Americans are very much discussing the
future of American forces in Iraq so
taking action that would force the
Americans to retaliate within Iraqi
territory will only add to tensions
between the Iraqi government and the
United States further uh increasing the
likelihood that the US would be asked to
leave so the Iranians have planned this
very carefully they're trying to put the
the Biden Administration in policy
dilemmas but I think ultimately
President Biden will have to retaliate
and some of that retaliation will come
on Iraqi soil how destabilizing has
Israel's war on Gaza been for the
region oh absolutely I mean I I I've
been saying for some time now that uh to
say that this is now an Israel Hamas war
is to miss the forest for the trees this
is now an Iranian American confrontation
that's the result of the Deton that fell
apart between the two countries and it
fell apart under the pressure and the
burden of the war in Gaza so yes what's
happening in Gaza is reverberating
throughout the region the American
Iranian Deton that was achieved in last
May that allowed for a cooling of these
various theaters of conflict across the
region and an an understanding on the
threshold of which Iran is allowed to
enrich uranium that has now completely
come apart so we need to see some kind
of resolution
to the conflict in Gaza to begin winding
that down in to start de escalating
conflicts elsewhere very interesting to
speak to you for as Max add thanks for
joining us there from Washington
DC my pleasure